Hello everyone and welcome to the humor
workshop part two.
Today's 60-minute program is part of the
Toastmasters public speaking webinar
series. My name is Linda Williams and I
am delighted to be with you today.
As many of us know, laughter is the best
medicine.
And while I'm not actually a doctor, I
do like to hand out prescriptions for
laughter whenever possible.
In real life, I'm actually a training
and development specialist with
Toastmasters International. Thank you so
much for joining us today. We're all
really excited looking at the chat right
now with everyone saying hello from all
over the world. Quite a few folks from
the United States coast to coast. I see
India, the Netherlands, Mexico, Bahrain.
There are so many great places. So,
thanks again for being with us.
Before you meet our moderator and our
panelists today, I wanted to take a few
minutes to set the stage for our time
together.
For the majority of this 1-hour
workshop, we'll be watching a live
discussion between members of our expert
panel.
Who I like to call our wizards of wit
and whimsy.
And as you receive today's dose of
laughter and learning, we expect you
might have some questions along the way.
Please use the Q&A panel on your screen
to submit the questions. And towards the
end of the workshop, we'll choose the
most difficult ones to ask our panel.
Not really. In all seriousness, with so
many attendees, we probably won't be
able to get to all of your questions,
but we'll certainly do our best and we
appreciate your patience and
understanding.
And while you will not be able to speak
aloud, we encourage you to keep using
that chat feature. Talk with one another
throughout the workshop.
If you're not familiar from the chat
drop-down box, remember to choose send
to all panelists and attendees so
everyone in the audience gets to hear
from you.
And we thank you in advance for always
remembering to be polite and courteous
to your fellow attendees.
Also, please keep in mind that our team
will be focused on answering questions
that are posted in the Q&A pane, not
questions posted in the chat.
This workshop is being recorded and
everyone will receive an email in a few
days with a link to the recording.
So, before I introduce our moderator,
our panel has asked me to find out how
often the members of our audience
actually laugh.
So, if you'd like to, please answer the
following question using the polling
feature you'll see pop up on your screen
in just a mo.
Just a moment.
You should be seeing it now. The
question is,
have you laughed today?
All right, I see answers coming in.
I'll give you about 5 more seconds to
answer that poll if you can and if you
want to.
All right.
Couple of answers still coming in.
Not a surprise.
I'm glad to hear yes, I've laughed
today. I try to laugh daily.
17 of you said, "I'm not funny."
Hmm.
Let's look at those results, shall we?
So, some of you have not laughed today
and it's a good reason you're here.
Thank you to the 113 of you who said
yes, they've already laughed today
because I am so funny.
All right. Let's move right along
and let me introduce with great pleasure
our workshop moderator, Mark Brown.
Mark's originally from Kingston, Jamaica
and he immigrated to the US when he was
18.
He had only $40 in his pocket
and a dream for a better life.
Those of you who might know Mark, in
1995,
he defeated more than 20,000 contestants
from 14 different countries to win the
illustrious title of Toastmasters
International World Champion of Public
Speaking.
Since that day, Mark has delivered more
than 3,500 presentations on five
different continents to more than 1.7
million people.
Please welcome one of the most popular
inspirational speakers in the world, the
fabulous and very funny Mark Brown.
Thanks so much, Linda. I think she meant
the fabulous and funny-looking Mark
Brown, but it's a joy to be here and I
can't wait to hear from today's
panelists. Our first is Stefan Dyer.
He's from Costa Rica originally. He's a
banker turned comedian. He's done over
400 shows in eight countries including
Peru, Mexico, and Malaysia. Now, 4 years
ago, 2017,
after being one of the youngest senior
managers at Scotiabank Toronto, he quit
his lucrative bank job to pursue a
professional career in stand-up comedy.
And since then, he's been on Second
City, TEDx, Comedy Central, and some of
the world's largest comedy festivals.
He's the co-founder and CEO of co-CEO of
of Malpensando,
an award-winning bilingual public
speaking and comedy school in Toronto,
Canada. He has empowered thousands of
people to become funny, confident
speakers.
Our second expert gets to wear two hats
having been a moderator for a panel
before. And she is Tammy Miller.
To hear her tell it, she's in the
business of changing lives.
She's the president and CEO of Tammy
Speaks and Tammy Miller Auctions.
Which are four her titles of
international speaker,
auctioneer, author, and speaking coach.
As an international speaker, her topics
include humor and healing, communication
skills, motivation, leadership, and
business and dining
etiquette.
Tammy is also, get this, a professional
clown who uses the healing power of
humor when visiting hospital patients.
She wrote a book about her battle with
breast cancer entitled The Lighter Side
of Breast Cancer Recovery.
Our third panelist today is Drew Tarvin.
A former engineer by profession, Drew
calls himself a humor engineer in that
he's teaching people every day how to
get better results while having more
fun. He's a corporate trainer, a
comedian, and a keynote speaker based in
New York. Sorry, New York.
As a speaker, he has delivered more than
5,000 talks to 35,000 and more people.
And his TEDx talk called The Skill of
Humor has almost 9 million views. As an
author, he's written three best-selling
books including Humor That Works, The
Missing Skill for Success and Happiness
at Work.
So, welcome Stefan, Drew, and Tammy.
We're going to get going We're going to
get going and we'll start with you,
Tammy. Now, you've worked as a
professional clown in hospitals. Please
tell us what's involved with that, what
you've learned from the process, and
what you've seen as a professional clown
in hospitals.
It's really a very, very interesting
journey, Mark, because, you know, when
you go into a hospital, first of all,
people are they don't really want to be
there for obvious reasons, right? But
it's interesting because you have to
really look at what is happening there
and they can't change why they're there.
So, when clowns go into hospitals and
look at that, they look at opportunities
that they can at least alleviate for
that particular moment in time what
they're thinking and feeling and maybe
bringing some levity and some humor and
just some love into it. So, in
hospitals, we look at just the patient
themselves one-on-one or in a group, but
it is always a wonderful loving
experience for sure.
That's like That's such noble work to do
while having fun at the same time. We're
going to really little deeper on that in
a couple seconds, but I want to go to I
want to go to Drew, the
humor engineer. And most people don't
put those two words together. So, for
those who are kind of going
explain that to us, Drew. What is a
humor engineer and how does that work
with laughter?
Certainly. Well, uh first, quick
shout-out to everyone joining today and
to those of you joining us from
yesterday. Quick little fun game you can
play if you did join us yesterday is
what's changed about my background.
Maybe you noticed it, maybe you didn't.
Uh fun little thing to have. But uh in
the meantime, to answer the question of
humor engineer, if you've never heard of
a humor engineer, it's because I made it
up. Uh but
the reason I made it up is as a way to
best explain what I do. My background is
in computer science and engineering and
as a computer science engineer working
at Procter & Gamble, I would solve
problems using computers, things like
technology, spreadsheet programming,
etc. And as I started to become more of
a speaker, a trainer, consultant, etc.,
I realized I was still solving workplace
problems, things like employee
engagement, stress management,
leadership, communication, etc. Uh but I
was using humor instead and so I decided
to combine the two and say, "Okay, well,
I'm a humor engineer. I use humor to
solve workplace challenges."
Well, real quickly, follow-up question
for that. Do you find that companies are
actually looking for more humor in the
workplace, especially since we've going
been going through a pandemic now?
Uh yes and no. Uh very few people are
searching for humor in the workplace.
You get about a thousand global monthly
searches on Google. Uh but what they are
searching for are things that humor can
solve and that's a key part of using
humor is not talking about, "Hey, humor
for the sake of humor." but rather, "Are
you having issues with stress
management? Are you finding it more
difficult to communicate and effectively
connect with people in a virtual way,
etc.?" Are you missing the levity from
the, you know, casual interactions of
the office? And that's where we can say,
"Oh, absolutely humor can help us to do
that thing." Also, quick shout-out to
the people in the chat. They have found,
yes, this has changed and we've got a
new Calvin and Hobbes uh painting that
my brother made for me cuz I'm a huge
Calvin and Hobbes fan.
And someone did say the mic's missing as
well. I mean, we can't see over your
shoulder, but so there you go.
Stefan, my friend, your bio tells us you
didn't just leave a job, you left a
lucrative corporate job as a rising
star, fast-track whiz kid to be a
full-time comedian. Why in the world
would you do that and how has it worked
out for you?
Oh my god. I'll I'll be completely
honest. I miss the recurring paycheck.
Cuz even if you didn't do anything at
the bank, you'd still get paid every 2
weeks and that was glorious. Uh but the
what um
the reason why I did it is because
I started doing comedy on the side and I
started seeing what it had done for me.
It was therapeutic. I was having lots of
fun. My brother, uh Kurt, in Costa Rica,
I'm from Costa Rica, he is also he was
also part of Procter & Gamble and he
quit his full-time job in 2008 as well
to be a musician. So, I kind of had that
he did it first. So, while it was a
shock for my family,
it wasn't as big as the first time with
my big brother.
Um
it's
I can't explain it. You know, if you've
ever been in a cubicle and you're like,
"I don't know if I can be here for
another
10 years." It was and nothing nothing
wrong. I I'm so grateful for my 7 years
at at the bank. I was in wealth
management helping manage uh
millionaires' money and
I'm grateful because I wouldn't be as
good as I am today at what I do had I
not been there. People think that it's
just being on stage and making people
laugh, but that's like less than 1% of
the time of your
everything of your day. You got to be
good at marketing, selling, negotiating,
finance, accounting, everything.
So, that was my school and now into the
real world where if I don't sell and
make fun and make people laugh, I don't
eat.
It's
it's a lot harder, but it's definitely
um
fulfilling. I knew I had to do it and I
just pictured myself two things. When
I'm 60, 70, 80, I don't want to look
back and be like, "What if?"
And the second thing was that I I knew
that if I continued in that cubicle,
I would always, every single day, be
like,
"I would have wasted my time. I I don't
know what I could have accomplished."
So, I just had to try. I saved up and
then I was like, "If it doesn't work
out, I'll come back to the bank in 1
year." Well, you know what? I'm I so
appreciate that comment. I know Kami
wants to kind of riff on that and I'll
let her, but you used the word just now.
You said you found humor to be
therapeutic. And I want to bounce that
to you, Tammy, because you're in
hospitals where people are in dire
situations. And I'm just wondering what
what do you find to be the therapeutic
impact of humor, especially as a clown
in hospitals?
Well, I was actually just going to
piggyback on what he had said because
when I left my full-time job to go into
speaking and being an auctioneer, it was
because, you know, where I worked was
feeding my family, but it wasn't feeding
my soul. Yes. Exactly what he's talking
about. You know, we have to go where it
feeds our soul. And whether we're
working in a hospital with people or
we're just simply in the world, the
therapeutic part of humor is so very,
very important because you don't have to
be in a hospital bed to to be in dire
straits because, you know, especially
right now in the middle of the pandemic
when we have a lot of people who are
isolated or depressed or stressed, major
stress, you know, the the humor part of
it comes in where we have to say, "Oh my
gosh, what can I control?" because
everything else is spinning out of
control. So, it's really important what
he's talking about that we take that and
just like look at each each moment and
go, "Uh, this is really kind of
overwhelming, but all right, what really
is happening here? Come on, let's face
it, you know?" And that's really when we
can kind of break that down and then
that helps relax us and control a little
bit more of what we can control and
that's ourselves, not our environment as
much, but ourselves.
That's really cool if we can control
ourselves. So, this humor has kind of a
can play a bigger role in everybody's
life if we give it a chance.
But your life just makes me go, "What in
the world?" because not only are you a
humorist and a clown, I mean, physically
a clown, and I met someone once who told
me they flunked clown school. I didn't
know that was possible. But you're also
an auctioneer. Mhm. Is there anything
funny about being an auctioneer? Give us
a little Give a couple of lines. Give us
a little riff here so we can hear what
it sounds like. Oh, I love being an
auctioneer, absolutely. I do all types
of auctions, but I specialize in
fundraising and real estate. So, what I
love as far as the fundraising part of
it is, it is all humor. It is all
engagement. It is all laughter because,
you know, if you're asking somebody, in
some cases you're asking for $100, in
some cases you're asking for $50,000,
right? But I love being engaged with the
audience and making them laugh. So, I
always say that being an auctioneer is
really just being a speaker with a
little bit faster pace to it. So, if I'm
out there going, "$5 over down 10, 10
over down 15, 15 over down 20, 20 over
down 25." You know, so it's it's just
really a lot of fun and the rhythm gets
you going. So, I just love doing that
with people. Some fun activities we
often times find is in an auction, I
might have a husband in front of me,
well, normally it's the other way
around. Normally, it's the the the wife
is in front of me at the table, the
husband's back at the bar getting the
drinks and they're bidding against each
other for something and they don't
realize they're bidding against each
other.
And I just let them bid, you know? Oh,
hey. And then at some point in time,
I'll, you know, play around with them a
little bit and say, "Oh, did you realize
you're bidding against your husband?"
So, it is fun and it's it's really how
can you find that funny? You said it
earlier. How can you find the funny?
That's what it's about, Mark. That's
awesome. Finding the funny and we
mentioned work and job and
auctioneering. And Drew, I know you say
you're the humor engineer.
We we You've done some consulting work
with some amazing organizations. And
people would think are, you know, pretty
serious. You've got the Red Cross,
they're saving lives and the UN trying
to solve world problems and the FBI.
Oof, get my little earpiece in here. But
how can serious groups learn from
improv, from humor, having fun while
handling very serious issues?
Well, it's it's a great question, Mark.
I appreciate it. Very quickly, before I
answer that one, I just want to touch
upon what both
your soul. I love that, Tammy. I think
it's helpful for some people to
recognize that you don't have to do what
you love, but rather love what you do.
And that I think is an important
distinction because some people are
going to leave the job like Stefan did,
like I happened to do, etc. But some
people might might not be in a situation
where they can kind of like, "Oh, I'm
just going to go and do comedy." But
rather, by using humor intentionally in
the workplace, you can find ways to
enjoy whatever it is that you're doing
and that's going to lead to more
success. When we have uh enjoyment in
our work, what we say, "What gets fun
gets done." And that applies in some of
these serious types of roles as well.
What's interesting is, particularly like
say our work with the Red Cross, is
they recognize that just because
something is serious or important, it
doesn't mean that it's inherently
interesting.
Right? So, just because you have a
message that you really think the
audience needs to hear, doesn't mean
that they're going to stay engaged. And
this is what they were talking about
with the Red Cross is if they're talking
about disaster preparedness, messages
that could save your life given a flood
or a tornado or a drought or whatever
they're training on,
boredom has very serious consequences.
And so, how can we use humor as a way to
adapt? And the absolute answer is yes.
Using humor in our communication or
using humor in the way that we present
or train or connect with people doesn't
mean that we don't take what we do
seriously. It just means that we know
how important it is to resonate with
that audience, something which humor can
do very, very well.
Now, I'm so glad you mentioned that,
resonating with audiences. Now, we're
dealing with we're dealing with
Toastmasters and much of our focus is on
the presentation and giving the speech.
And very often we don't think of the
physical side of comedy and humor. For
example, Drew, you asked us to look at
what was different behind you.
And I think what a cool prop. There's a
camera back there. There's a different
thing. Like, do you ever use props in
your talk, Drew?
Uh I don't use a tremendous amount of
props, but I do think that activities
are a great thing to do. Now, certainly
every now and then, if you joined
yesterday, I actually used the mute
button in Zoom kind of as a prop almost
in a sense for for uh humor. But, I
think exactly to your point, Mark, is
that you don't have to think of humor as
just set up and punchline or just making
people laugh, but rather things like an
activity. So, for example, one of the
things that I love to do, and everyone
can do this kind of now as a physical
activity as an example, is uh you can go
ahead and point forward on your left
hand, so I'll mirror it for you, and
then give a thumbs up on your right
hand. I'd love for the panelists to try
this as well. You guys can jump in,
right? Bring your forward, thumb up, and
now just switch the two.
Right? Can be difficult. And you can
switch back
and forth and back and forth. And the
panelists are doing pretty well, but
like every now and then people will have
like a finger gun or they'll have like a
finger up or down or whatever. Like,
yeah, you're trying to text your friend.
This is a simple exercise. This is
something that if you're doing this as a
training in a Toastmasters like an event
where you have to speak and you want to
send a message, right? This is something
fun, interesting that's a little bit
different. So, it's going to make people
smile or laugh, and you can connect this
to the conscious competence learning
model or to trying something new or the
idea of getting over failure, right? it
doesn't have to be just this strict
stand-up comedy set up punchline. But,
there's other forms of humor as well.
Stefan, what do you use for physical
humor, props, anything like that in your
in your programs?
So, that's that's such an incredible
question and topic because I I always
try
to have lots of tools in my show. And at
the end of the day, it's it's not a
presentation. I like to see it as an
experience. What do I want people to
feel? Like Maya Angelou said, people
will forget what you said, people will
forget what you did, but they'll never
forget how you made them feel. And
at the beginning of my comedy career, I
was very book-oriented. I read all the
books, I studied all the books, I took
notes, so I was going in with only set
up and punch. And
20% of the time I would kill it, and 80%
of the time I'd get nothing. I'm like,
why?
It's the same set, but just with a
different audience. Why are they not
laughing? And then I realized like every
audience is is totally different. First
of all, I always arrive early to see
them and study them, talk to them, and
see what they're like. But, then what I
also do is, okay, I got my set really
real well prepared.
I got physical, I got accents, I got
tonality, and I'm crowd working.
Sometimes the material may not kill, but
it could be like one thing that you're
not expecting. Like this one show I did
in Montreal, there was a guy who looked
exactly like Vin Diesel. And I was just
like, what do you think about this, Vin
Diesel? And everyone laughed. Like it
just exploded. It was just like that key
that you needed to touch so that
and then the the show, same material,
the show just
smooth sailing after that. And probably
they won't remember my show, but they
remember the Vin Diesel guy, like the
Vin Diesel comedian who made fun of the
Vin Diesel guy. So, I I am
a lot very physical when I talk about
Latino stuff or dancing or parts where
it requires for you to be physical.
There's parts where it requires for you
to do deadpan,
pauses,
faces without talking. But, if you have
a really cool combination of things, you
never know what that audience may need,
and just that little thing that you need
for it to go on that way.
It's you never really know. As soon as
you touch that key, you'll just ride the
wave, and then it'll be smooth sailing
after that.
Oh, thanks, Stefan. That one little
thing. Now,
Gabi, that one little thing as a clown
is really a big thing because people are
seeing you, the costume, the look in
itself adds to the image they have of
you and the expectation.
How significant is the physical aspect
of humor and comedy? And how can you
link that to what we can do as
Toastmasters and speakers who tend to
focus so much on the words and not so
much on the physical?
Well, I think it really comes down to
being relatable to your audience. You
know, we're all in this together. I say
that many, many times, and those of us
who have the the honor of being able to
travel into different cultures, we find
that we are all in this together. So, it
doesn't matter if you're in Malaysia,
Singapore, uh
Canada, it doesn't really matter where
you are.
People love to be able to laugh. And I
have a real quick story. I was in
Bulgaria, we were teaching at the
International House of Humor.
And in that particular case, we had the
honor of going into some children's
hospitals. And where we were, they did
not speak English, and we did not speak
their language. So, there were a couple
of us clowns, and we're trying to figure
out, how are we going to connect with
this audience? And I will say that it
was a blessing from God. That's just my
personal opinion, because I put a kazoo
in my mouth, and I said to the clown
beside me, do you know how to do balloon
animals? She wasn't quite as
experienced, and she said, I think I can
follow you. So, I put a kazoo in, and
she put a kazoo in, and as I twisted the
balloon, we went beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep beep. And she went
And it was within seconds. I still get
chills. It was within seconds. The whole
room, these children, nurses, doctors,
we didn't know the language, but we all
laughed together. And it was one of the
most heartwarming experiences I've ever
had. So, I think it's finding that
relatable part, and that's what it's not
really even the physical as much as how
can I relate to this audience? How can I
tell you what's happening and make that
relate to you? So, as Toastmasters, many
people here are Toastmasters, not
everyone, but we're always looking for
ways to add that humor. How are we going
to relate what's happening in our lives?
Because let's face it, guys, life is
funny, right?
Going to relate what's happening in our
lives to relate to our audience and
build that bridge, and that's exactly
what Stefan was just talking about. And
Drew, you know, it's we're all looking
at it from different angles, but we're
looking at the same thing.
So, where's the kazoo? Come on, Gabi,
where's the kazoo? Where's the kazoo?
I don't even have one handy, Mark. We
want we want to see you because a video
would be so powerful to see you you
know, see you use a technique or an
improv. And Stefan, putting you on on
the spot real quickly, do you have a
particular improv technique you just you
do all the time that works for you or
something that you show the audience
physically? I am a fan of the
look-alikes.
And
I'll crowd work at the beginning of my
shows, and I always say, oh my god, I
didn't know so many celebrities would
show up to the show. Here we got but I'm
I already wrote them down before because
I'm I'm I'm
like I'm I'm writing before my show
observations about my audience. And then
people think that, oh my god, this guy
is so like spontaneous or but no, we've
done this before. It sounds cool, and it
sounds looks spontaneous, but through
repetition, and obviously I can't I
don't know before the show who's going
to show up. But, I I'm writing them down
on my little paper, and when I go, I'll
crowd work for the first 5 minutes, and
I'll do that, and then I'll get the
countries going, get the cities going,
milk a little bit of the stereotypes,
see feel my audience, and if they like
the stereotypes, they like the
look-alikes, then I know it's a green
light for me, and then I can go all in.
Or if not, then I just know that it's
okay. I'll just do my normal material,
and I won't really
like rely on that as much because if
they're not really having it, you don't
want to
continue
spending time on that because you're
going to
waste
your credibility, and and people may not
like you. So,
um I'm starting slow, conversationally,
crowd working. If they like it, I go
hard. If not, I continue with the game
plan.
Now, Stefan, you mentioned something
that I want to throw to Drew. You said
it looks spontaneous, but I've taken my
notes. I had a mentor who used the
phrase, Drew, rehearsed spontaneity.
It looks spontaneous, but it's
rehearsed. Do you use any kind of
technique, Drew, that would might mirror
rehearsed spontaneity, and how do you
use them?
Certainly. Uh I uh first shout out to
Stefan. I think the celebrity look-alike
is a great example of that. Uh for those
who have asked me for me, yeah. Yeah,
Topher Grace, or I get skinny Hugh
Jackman sometimes. Uh my favorite though
is after an event once, a woman came up
to me afterwards, and she's like, I
think you look like Justin Timberlake,
but from here to here.
Just just the eyeballs of JT. But, uh to
your point about splan- plan
spontaneity, part of it is I think this
is the value of being extemporaneous,
right? There's as a comedian, if you've
written a lot of material, I wasn't
planning on doing this today, but that
is material that I've said before in the
past, oh, there's a point that I can
bring it in, and now it feels like it's
completely potentially made up on the
spot, but it's actually something that
has some of that practice behind it. So,
I think that's one way to do it. Uh I
think another is understanding
framework. So, this is big within the
world of improvisation, and so I use a
lot of applied improv in my training and
recognizing, oh, as just as Stefan does
it, you can create a structure where not
like, hey, I'm going to plan for this
part to be somewhat spontaneous. Having
done it a number of times, I'm going to
have that practice and repetition of
knowing what it's like, but it's very
structured. And that structure just
makes the process easier. It doesn't
make it less creative. And then to your
question, Mark, on on improv in general,
as I mentioned, I think applied improv
is a fantastic way to do some training.
And if we have a moment, I can do a
quick exercise maybe at some point
today, but it is a way for people to not
only
learn what kind of content you're
talking about, but to experience it
themselves.
Now, I'm curious. Tammy, have you
Have you done improv yourself, Tammy?
Yes. You You got improv. Stefan's done
improv improv. Andrew has done improv.
You know what sounds like fun?
I'd love for you to do a little improv
right now. Folks, this is not rehearsed.
I haven't chosen my topic yet. I'm going
to wing it.
But does If I give you a scenario, can
you kind of riff on that? How would How
How would you Drew, how would you create
an improv set a skit? Help me out here.
Well, there's a couple of things that
come to mind. We could either do a very
specific game. So, I'm a big fan of
something like first letter last letter,
which has a certain structure to it,
which you can explain to people as they
play it. Or you kind of just give a
suggestion and then improvisers one of
the fundamental mindset of improvisation
is this idea of yes and. And so, rather
than you tell us something and we're
going to like argue back and forth of
what it is, it's whatever you say, we're
going to decide to build off of what
each other talks about so that we create
a more compelling experience as opposed
to arguing about something that isn't
real. Well, I see Stefan kind of
nodding. So, I want to let you vote.
Stefan and Tammy, which of those two do
you want to do? First letter last letter
or yes and?
Yes and. I mean, yes and is the the rule
number one anyways, but yeah, yes and
and then give us a place, a situation,
and we'll just run with it. Take it
away, Drew. Go for it.
All right, excellent. So, all I need is
in the chat, can I get a suggestion of a
location that you absolutely love a
place. Oh, a beach is the first thing
that I saw when I
saw We're going to go with the first
answer of that. The answer is Sorry,
suggestion of a location is beach, and
that's kind of all we need to get
started with a little bit of a scene.
So, I'll step back for a moment and
allow Tammy and Stefan to start.
Stefan, go ahead.
Ay ay ay ay ay, Tammy. I love this
beach. It seems like I want to do yoga,
but also going to the water. What do you
want to do?
Oh my gosh, you know, it's so incredible
to be out here. And I was really excited
because you you're not going to believe
I saw all these purple people coming
down the beach, and they were carrying
on their shoulders going woo woo woo
woo. And I realized it was none other
than Mark Brown on their shoulders. Oh
my god, the purple people and Mark
Brown, the voice of God, the VOD. Oh my
god, was he wearing his bow tie? Oh, he
was. He was wearing the bow tie. You
would not have believed what he was
doing. But then when they went further
down the beach, I turned around and
realized it wasn't just Mark Brown. It
was also Drew was with him. I thought,
what are these two doing out here on the
beach? It was so cool. Guys Guys Guys
Guys, Stefan and Tammy, oh my god, I'm
so excited. Mark has promised he's going
to teach me how to improvise rap on the
beach. We said, let's come down to the
beach, let's get into the sand, and he's
like, I'm going to drop some rhymes for
you. Can you believe it? Can we give him
a little bit of excitement and maybe
cheer him on because I think he's going
to totally
Now, I've never had a kazoo before in a
rap contest. But you know what? As a
speaker, I've been told I'm the best. I
could keep going, but I'm going to give
you a rest because now I'm going to give
Stefan a chance. Will you pass the test?
Oh my Wake up, Mr. West, Mr. Fresh, Mr.
By himself, he's so impressed. I mean,
damn, did you even see the test?
It's Mr. West.
Now, I'm going to confess to the whole
world, to 2,000 people watching live, I
have never, and I repeat, never ever
done that in my life. But you know what?
But it was fun. And Tammy got the kazoo
going, had some fun with that as well.
And it just kind of taught me very
quickly that we can improvise, have fun,
find a way to bring some rhythm to it. I
mean, Stefan, you brought your accent to
bear. I didn't bring mine because you
wouldn't understand it. But there's so
many ways we can do this, and it could
be a fun exercise. And as as
Toastmasters, we have table topics. And
we've played various games where one
person begins the story, somebody else
continues to the end, but this was
really fun to inject the music, the
visual, the atmosphere. That was really
really cool. People Now, I know that
Drew is is kind of watching the chat
really fast because Drew can read a lot
faster than I can. What are you seeing
there, Drew? Well, there's yeah, there's
a lot of excitement in the chat,
happiness, fun, congratulations. In
fact, can we get some exclamation points
in the chat for Mark? Because what I did
there was I very intentionally set him
up, and and sometimes you can do that,
but I knew Mark had the skill set and
the capability to do it. And a couple of
things just to to maybe I don't think
take the fun out of it, but
from an applied improv standpoint, when
we do that with our audiences or our
client, one of the most valuable parts
of the experience is the debrief. It's
to talk a little bit about that to help
the audience connect what was fun to
what they're trying to learn. Because I
will admit, sometimes early on in my
career, I would do improv exercises like
this, and people would like be like,
that was fun, but I don't see how that's
going to help me be a better nurse or a
better project manager or a better
manager. And so, the debrief helps you
connect those pieces, and we can come
back and talk about either the, you
know, treating each other like geniuses
and poets and yes anding each other's
ideas, the point of having fun,
you know, even if you're not sure of
what's going to happen, still delivering
something with confidence. That debrief
part becomes really valuable in terms of
leaving a lasting impression. And now,
rather than us just talking about
improv, we've actually demonstrated it,
something that everyone can be a part
of.
Now, I I don't want to thank you all for
that because that felt You know what? It
I feel an actual rush to my system
because truly, I have never ever tried
to rap or to rap spontaneously for 2,000
people
ever before. Tammy, what's your comment?
Well, my comment was, you know, I always
tell people when I'm talking about
Toastmasters, I say, you never know what
you're being prepared for. And while
we're talking about that, about things
that might be serious in life, and
Toastmasters helps prepare us to be able
to go out and present and do that, but
this is exactly what Drew's talking
about, too, because, you know, we're
being prepared that we have a little bit
of a a funny bone, that sense of humor
that we can, whatever given the
situation, that we can play. And that
was That was really perfect. You guys
did a great job
letting me play along. I love that. I
got a question for each of you, though.
As speakers, and I think it might help
those who are watching who are more used
to speaking, some of us are so keyed up,
we want to do well, and we're in a live
situation, and something happens,
something goes wrong, uh somebody's
phone rings, uh a a cat or a dog makes a
sound, something happens, a siren starts
going, and we get thrown off.
From each of you, I'll go I'll go Drew,
then Stefan, then Tammy. What
spontaneous
responses can you give when something
happens, a distraction, a heckler, or an
unexpected thing that could throw you
off? Again, Drew, Stefan, and then
Tammy, how do you respond in the moment
when something goes wrong? Yeah, and I
think it's a great point. This is what
we in comedy call calling the moment or
calling the room, and it's a very
important thing to do because if you're
speaking and someone drops a glass and
it shatters everywhere, the audience is
going to be like, did that person see
that happen? And until you address it,
they're going to be distracted. But as
soon as you address it, and it
oftentimes if you can use humor to do
it, then it eases the situation, people
are like, oh great, now we can move on
from it. I think within that, back to
that idea of planned spontaneity, is you
can plan for certain things that are
going to happen. You know eventually the
mic is going to drop or the lights are
going to go out or in Zoom someone's
going to be muted for a little bit.
Right? You can plan for certain things
to happen and and get have backups ready
for them. One of the big questions that
people ask is, what do you do if you
tell a joke and it doesn't land or it
doesn't work. And so, that's an example
of calling the moment. And some
comedians, one of my favorite comedians,
Eddie Izzard, she's amazing. She'll take
out of an imaginary notebook and then
write a note to herself and be like,
okay, never tell that joke again.
That was funnier than they gave credit
for. Or whatever it is, and that allows
that Okay, hey, we've all called the
moment of what's just happened, we can
laugh about it, and now we're moving on
to the next thing.
Awesome. Stefan?
I totally agree with Drew. It's You have
to use what's available. If it didn't
land, then make a joke
about it. But I've I've done it, and
then I've seen other comedians do it
like 13 times in a row, and then it's
not funny anymore because
it's just you're not funny. The set is
not funny. So, I think for like two or
like one or two or three times it'll
it'll work, and you have to like see if
the crowd is still loving it on the
fourth time. The other thing is,
like Drew said, if they're paying more
attention to the spilled beer or the
people's whispering or whatever, you
have to address it. Otherwise, like you
already lost. They're not even paying
attention to you anymore. So, you you
have to address it. And then,
the other thing that I've that I've done
is
ooh, like the mic went off or the
batteries of the of the wireless mic
went off, and it had happened to me
initially in my career, and I didn't
know what to do.
So now, like Drew said, I was prepared,
and I started doing the show without the
mic for like 3 minutes until I got a new
mic. And they were loving cuz I was
screaming, I was making fun of myself, I
was like doing callbacks to the show,
and clearly they could see me suffering
because I was had to yell, but I was
making fun of my yelling. And then if it
goes too much and it's too uncomfortable
or you nobody can listen to you or the
lights are not working or it's like
unhandled like you can't handle it, but
another little trick that I learned is
nobody will ever complain about a
5-minute break.
If you can't control it, if it's just
gets out of control or there's a fight
or whatever,
we're just going to take a 5-minute
break and we'll be right back. Just go
have some water, go to the bathroom,
we'll be right back. And everybody loves
that, nobody's going to complain.
Everyone's going to come back and we're
going to continue the show. So, point
out the elephant in the room or call the
room like Drew said, and if it gets out
of control,
5-minute break never hurt anyone.
Thanks so much, Tammy.
Oh, I totally agree with what my
colleagues are saying. You know, you
have to address it because if you don't,
you're you're distracted. So, not only
you're you're distracted, the audience
is distracted. You have to embrace it
and just go with it. I did kind of I was
kind of curious with Stefan though. You
know, how often do fights break out at
your comedy show?
Here is where where you're really
performing here. I've I've performed in
many rough places.
I don't know, maybe like three in my
career.
Yeah. Well, I love to play with the
audience, too. But that goes back to
what we said very very early at the
beginning. You know, often times when
you're meeting the people as they're
coming in and then something happens,
you can go to that person, you can go to
the people that you were talking with
and have them play along and say, "Did
you see that? Oh my gosh, I cannot
believe that woman looked, you know,
whatever the case is." So, it really has
to do with the entire scene, the entire
audience, not just one moment in time,
but seeing the entire audience and how
you address something that can be very
disrupting to you and for the audience.
Okay. Now, and that's the same point,
Drew, our humor engineer. Do you create
a list of go-tos in certain scenarios?
And if so, can you share a few of them?
Certain certain unexpected scenarios as
is there a go-to list of responses?
Uh yes, certainly. So, I think um one if
um if my my if I might get muted for
whatever reason in a virtual scenario,
then after I come back off of mute, I'll
say, "Listen, that last tip was so
important that the government shut it
down. They didn't even want you to hear
it." I'm going to repeat it one more
time so you actually hear what's going
to be said. Uh so, I think that's a a
great one for uh if the if I say a joke
and the audience doesn't laugh, a lot of
times I will just move past it cuz
what's interesting is if you have
positive inclusive humor,
if it's a joke that no one laughs at, it
just goes from a joke to a now positive
inclusive statement, right? It's not a
thing that I have to be like awkwardly
like, "Hey, did you laugh? Did you get
that?" or other things. Or I'll
sometimes poke fun of myself of like,
"Clearly, I think it's funnier than
uh you all." I think it's also valuable
one of the things in in Stefan may do
this as well uh is comedians will
sometimes have pet jokes. And you talked
about it a little bit earlier is like
for example, Mark, you and I have talked
about I love puns. So, I'll say a pun at
the beginning of my presentation,
something like uh a man once asked if I
wanted a free fish. So, I asked, "What's
the catch?"
Boom boom, right? Exactly. And so, if if
the audience laughs, then it's like,
"Okay, great. I can do more puns a
little bit later." If they groan,
"Great. I'm going to do more puns later,
but I'm also going to have that fun back
and forth about it." If there's no
response whatsoever, then it's like,
"Okay, I know that I can adjust my humor
as I go forward and I won't do puns, but
maybe I'll do more storytelling." So,
I'll adapt my entire presentation or set
based on the reactions people are
giving.
Oh, thank you. And Stefan, is there one
or two definite the go-tos if a phone
rings or a siren sounds and you can't
hear you? Do you have a go-to prepared
responses for that in the middle of your
presentation?
Well, yeah, I I I don't have it like
prepared, but I'll definitely if it's
too loud and she picks up or he picks
up, I'm going to go there and I'm going
to be like, "No, pick up. We want to
talk to your mom." And then I'll I'll
get them to come up and we'll
get the call together. And then I I need
to do it cuz people are paying more
attention to the phone call than than
me.
So, it's it's very important to to but
it all comes back to like Drew and Tammy
said that you need to understand your
audience because
if this is the CEO of the company that
hired me, I'm not going to
risk the presentation and the mood
because of this little joke. I mean,
it could work, but there's a lot of
risk. So, but if I know because I've
been seeing him or I've been talking or
I've been seeing her and I know they're
playful, then I'll do it. And it's very
important that you don't take it
personally the reactions of the people
to your punchlines into your jokes cuz
that can throw you off. Like Drew was
saying yesterday, you have to assume
that you're crushing it. Mhm. But also
you have to really be aware of
what risks can you take. So, if
someone's like this,
I'm not going to take a risk of trying
to
get this guy to participate in my show
and get the crowd work because he
doesn't look like he wants to crowd work
and want to be part of my show. But the
people who are nodding and they're
leaning in, I know they'll contribute to
my show. So, I got to pick my battles
and I got to know who to talk to and who
to crowd work with and who I can kind of
pick on in some ways. So, it's it's a it
comes with experience, but you can't
really analyze the audience and be
present if you don't know your material
well. Cuz if you don't know it well,
you're going to be worried about and
they can tell if you don't know cuz your
eyes go, "And uh no, so as I was telling
you um yeah." And they can tell you're
improvising. So, you have to really know
your material well. Like I practiced 20
times in the previous 2 days before my
shows so that I am super confident about
it and I can be present. Otherwise,
I'm going to be suffering the whole the
whole night.
Well, our time has fast fleeted. I've
got one last short answer question for
each of you. Uh
Tammy first, then Stefan, and then Drew.
What is your one quick tip for everybody
to finding funny? How do we just find
funny around us? One quick tip, Tammy,
then Stefan, then Drew, and then Linda
will take over.
It takes a little bit of practice. Look
at everything and say, "What is funny
about that?" And give yourself a list
and give yourself the permission to be
funny and go with it. Thanks. Stefan.
Carry a humor notebook like Drew said
yesterday. Carry a humor notebook
because
the more you advance in your career,
you'll realize that it's not the words,
but it's more your delivery and your
view of the world. But at the beginning,
I was saying the same things that I'm
saying now, but nobody was laughing.
It's just that now I know how to say it
because I know myself better. But I
can't say anything if I don't have my
humor notebook of the things that I find
funny in my world view. Thank you. Drew,
he stole your point, but find something
else.
No, it's it's a great point. All of the
points are great. And the last thing is
I would say make it a habit. Try to
force yourself. And this is where you
know I when I first started when Twitter
came out, it was a great thing cuz it
was like, "I want to post a pun every
single day." And you know, then force
yourself to spend whether it's 2 minutes
or 20 minutes. Like I got to come up
with something. What can I do? But hold
yourself accountable, create a little
writers group within your Toastmasters
organization or a group of friends or
whatever and say, "Okay, let's each try
to share something each day that is a
simple observation or a joke." And that
will help get you into the habit of
creating.
Drew, Stefan, Tammy, thank you all so
much. Linda, I return the control to
you. Thank you.
Thank you all so much. I was muted, but
I was laughing out loud, especially the
rap. You have definitely raised the
level of laughter. I can't imagine if I
did my poll again that anyone would say
that they haven't laughed today. We have
gotten so many questions um come in from
our audience. So, I want to jump right
in and get into some of those. You've
you've answered some of them along the
way um but one of the ones or one of the
themes I should say that that has come
up is related to virtual presentations
and virtual speeches and just virtual
meetings. So, I'm going to start with
Drew. Um everyone of course can
uh jump in to answer part of the
questions, but we want to get quite a
few questions in if we can in the time
we have left. So, starting with Drew, um
a couple of questions specifically from
Harry and AJ,
but because so many of us are virtual
and we're not all using video and audio,
how do we hold for laughs? You know, how
do we deal with that lack of the
audience feedback regarding timing for
delivery and pausing for those
reactions?
It's a great question and uh you know,
one as as kind of Stefan alluded to and
we chatted briefly about this yesterday
is one assume that you're crushing it.
Have that confidence and just kind of
deliver cuz that's going to come across.
And actually something that Mark said uh
yesterday, somewhat as a a joke I think,
but it actually can work is if you're
newer to some material, sometimes having
another human being in the room with you
helps. Whether that is a you know, a
loved one who is also at home or um
a friend that you are double bubbling
with or whatever it is, but having
another human in the room that is kind
of nodding and and smiling can can
certainly help. And I think, you know,
recognize that uh you do a disservice to
your message and to your audience if you
are second-guessing your material in the
moment. That goes back to Stefan's point
of practice. It's like do do do the hard
work up front so that when you're there,
you can be in the moment and adapt to
it. And leave a little slightly longer
pause because it you don't want to step
on your laughter. That's probably the
one of the common early mistakes that
people new into humor do is they say
something that's actually funny, but it
might take a moment for the audience to
get. And so as the audience is just
getting to laugh, the speaker starts
speaking again and so then the audience
doesn't laugh because they're like,
well, now I want to hear what that
person says. So make sure that you're
not stepping on your laughter and give a
little bit more time. Because again,
even if people aren't laughing in that
moment, if you hold that moment
confidently, it doesn't feel like a
awkward what's going on. It just feels
like the person has confidence to take
up space. And real quick, I suggest this
also. Get a bunch of friends together,
have a little test Zoom meeting. Test
your material out and see if people
respond to you. You know, get a few Zoom
buddies. I don't know, from your club,
eight, nine, 10 of you. Hey, I got 3
minutes, let's go for it. And see their
response. You'll gain in confidence and
I'll give you an idea of how the real
audience will respond as well.
Mhm. Absolutely. Mhm.
All right, Tammy.
Being our I don't know, medical expert
on the panel, um we're going to start
with you, but can you speak at all to
the science behind the benefits of
laughter?
Uh there's there's really some
interesting research out there. I mean,
it basically start with Norman Cousins
in Anatomy of an Illness. I mean, he
still this day is considered to be the
father of that type of research. But
what they're really finding is that
laughter, and it doesn't have to even be
belly laughing, but just laughing and
enjoying, it will decrease your blood
pressure, it helps build the immune
system. So there's a lot of really
interesting pieces out there. There's a
in the article on Toastmasters magazine
has out
we cite some of those sources on how to
do that. I'm not the medical expert. I
certainly would not like to be able to
speak on going through breast cancer
with clown noses, kazoos, and rubber
chickens, but it's something that
happened. I didn't have a choice. So I
would certainly say go out there and
research that. Doesn't have to be strong
belly laughing, but there's a lot of
really good, especially related to the
heart, a lot of really good research out
there now about the humor and that
healing process.
Thank you, Tammy.
Um Stefan.
Um Ephron has asked, what can you
recommend to someone like him who
doesn't think he has a funny bone in his
body? And Amy also asked something
similar, you know, what helped you
transition using
um Toastmasters and and other resources
as a tool to help you make a change and
find your funny?
Well, as as I've said it in in the on
the magazine where I where I did an
article with many of you, I didn't know
that I was funny until I joined
Toastmasters. In a way because all my
speeches, even though even if they're
were serious, people were laughing and I
was like,
I'm trying to
So I I knew that I had something. Then I
started doing sketch comedy, little
comedy videos on Vine, and they were
it's the Vine is the TikTok for old
people.
I like that. TikTok, some of you
youngsters don't know what it is. So um
it's then I started seeing it, but I was
like,
I know I'll get there and be really
funny, but I don't have the time. I want
to get better now. Mhm.
Cuz it's so hard it's it's it's horrible
to fail on stage. Like it it So I'm
like, I need to read books and I need to
just copy the the blueprint of what the
the goats, the best have done. So my
recommendation is obviously get on
stage, the humor path of Toastmasters,
but the one book that I read by Judy
Carter, who's one of the best comedy
authors,
she's also on the official Toastmasters
podcast, like 12 20 episodes ago.
It's called Stand Up Comedy and by Judy
Carter. And she also has the Comedy
Bible and there there's lots of
exercises that you can do,
not jokes that people already know, from
your own experience, and then you can
just try them out with friends and they
don't have to know. Mhm. Absolutely.
Thank you. Thank you. To real, we're
going to shift gears a little bit. Um
Julius asked, what do you believe is the
greatest misconception about using humor
in training and development workshops,
virtual webinars, et cetera?
The greatest misconception. I think
there are a number of them, but I think
uh probably the biggest one, and we
spoke a little bit about it, is that
humor is not appropriate for serious or
somber topics. And I think the reality
is, right? If if the message that you
have is important, then you would want
to do every strategy that you have to
get an audience to be engaged in that
topic, of which we know humor to be an
incredibly powerful one. Now, obviously
there's a component to how do you do
that effectively? And one of the things
that I think is particularly helpful is
recognizing that you can
have humorous moments and then you can
have those somber moments or those
serious moments, and the delta change
between the two actually leaves much
more of an impact on an audience than if
you're just serious the entire time. And
in reality, if you're just funny the
entire time. But you can say, okay, if
you know you're getting ready to go into
something that tends to bring the room
down, but it's important for them to
hear, you can use a little bit of humor
before you head into it. Then you can
have that kind of discussion and then
you can use a little bit of humor as you
come out of it as well. And so I think
that's probably the biggest
misconception is that, no, I talk about
death or I talk about cancer or I talk
about
um you know, uh
child mutilation or other like these
things that are really important that we
need to have conversations about.
It's not about using humor throughout
the entire thing all the time, but in
the moments to to manage the the
audience. Mhm. Absolutely.
Great. Thank you. Thanks. Um Mark, I'm
going to put a question to you and
again, any of the panelists are welcome
um to to add their perspectives.
Michelle mentioned that many of us have
a concern about diversity, equity,
inclusion, et cetera. And thinking about
using humor, how do we
bridge that respect and support the
acceptance and open-mindedness, et
cetera. Any any tips or or perspectives
on that? Well, you know, we have to be
aware that the world is being much more
sensitive now to DEI, as they call it,
diversity, engagement, and inclusion. So
if it might cross the line, maybe you
don't want to do it. It's also one of
the reasons I think it's good to have
have a a mastermind group, people you
can bounce things off who are definitely
aware of what's happening. I would say
err on the side of caution. You know, I
was in the Middle East several years ago
and I was told very early on, three
topics to avoid, politics, sex, and
religion. And in my keynote, one of my
opening lines was, well, I was told not
to discuss politics, sex, and religion.
So I'll therefore address all three at
one time.
And they busted out laughing. But it was
in the context of the presentation. It
was about it was called together towards
tomorrow was their theme. I said, we
don't discuss these things because, you
know why? We don't make fun of these
things because it's divisive. We want to
be together. So we want to avoid
anything that's going to be called
causing any kind of division. So I said,
be ultra-sensitive, err on the side of
caution, and as Drew would say, try to
be as universal and as international as
possible so anybody can get a good laugh
without anybody feel anybody else
feeling that they were any little
discomfort or was that not really funny?
Was making fun of me? Now, truth be
told, there's several things to be aware
of these days and I'm learning more and
more as time goes by. But if your heart
is in the right place and you want to
serve well, it can make a difference.
And I know that Stefan is wants to go
all over the response to this. I'll let
him piggyback on that.
Thank you, Mike. So
so important what what Mike said and and
your audience and the event that you're
attending and the context in which
you're you're you're mentioning these
things. Obviously, in the in the comedy
world that I live in or the or the
corporate workshops and keynotes that I
give, because I'm Latino and in North
America it's it's a minority or because
Latinos have been uh
a victim in specific countries or
scenarios, and because it's my truth, I
get a buy. I can talk about it. And I
can also make fun of it because I am in
a way of the victim. So by me being the
vic- the victim as a as a Latino in some
ways or or the group that has been
marginalized in in other ways, I can
punch up towards the people who have
abused their power and nobody's going to
really get offended because if you get
offended, then you're really defending
the power abusers. So I've
I don't I don't say that I've made a
living out of it, but I my whole comedy
is about immigration and the hardships
and culture shock of moving to try to
get a better place, the Canadian dream,
the the American dream. So very
important to know the context and the
audience, but if it's your truth, I
don't think people can get offended.
Really?
And Oh, go ahead, Drew. Yeah, I was just
going to add uh like especially in the
the corporate environment, the the
stakes are much higher for the humor
that you use. The bar is much lower for
what's funny, but the stakes are higher.
And and my mom works in HR, which is
always often seen as a fun place. But my
mom likes to say, you can't spell humor
without HR. Uh cuz otherwise it'd just
be umo.
But so you can see where I get my sense
of humor from. But
the
and and to Mark's point, we were joking
before, I do have a flowchart of what's
appropriate not appropriate, but I think
that's the most helpful is if you're a
little bit older, then we call this a
newspaper rule. If you're a little bit
younger, we call this the woke Twitter
Twitter rule. And the rule is basically
if what would you be comfortable with
whatever joke or saying that you said
showing up on the front page of your
hometown newspaper or getting blasted
all over Twitter. And if you're like,
"I don't know if I'd want everyone in
the world to see I made this joke to
this group of people, then it's probably
not appropriate for the workplace.
Yeah. Really great point. And we don't
have time to ask more questions. So
before we wrap up, I do want all of you
members of our terrific panel to let the
audience know how can they connect with
you or find out more about you or find
out more about these resources you've
been talking about. So let's go in this
order. We will go Tammy, Stefan, Drew,
then Mark. Maybe 10 seconds. Where can
they find you and find out more?
All right, the easiest place to find me
is at Tammyspeaks, t a m m y s p e a k
s.com. It has information about the
speaking and the auctions as well. So
glad to be here today.
You can find me on LinkedIn or
Instagram. And you can see my name here
on the Zoom, Stefan Dyer.
And stefandyer.com.
Uh let's see. So I just shared in the
chat a link to a free humor personality
assessment that we're doing recently. So
you can either click that or go to
humorthatworks.com.
If you want to connect with me
personally or just want puns, I'm on
@drewtarvin on all social media. That
includes Twitter, LinkedIn, and I still
have a MySpace page. I don't know why
MySpace still exists.
But if you're on MySpace and that's
where you want to connect, it's also
@drewtarvin. That's where you wrap it
up. Antiques Roadshow, right? Antiques
Roadshow. You can get me of course at
@markleobrown on Twitter. I am Mark
Brown CSP on LinkedIn. My website is
markbrownspeaks.com
and tune into the world's only podcast
for speakers, the Unforgettable
Presentations Podcast at
unforgettablepresentationspodcast.com.
Well, thank you all so much, Mark,
Stefan, Tammy, and Drew for spending
this great hour of laughter with all of
us today. We so appreciate laughing with
you, hearing about your stories, your
insights. And members of the audience,
oh my gosh, this has been so much fun.
Thank you for being with us. Thank you
for engaging in the chat. As I mentioned
earlier, we will be sending the
recording of today's workshop to
everybody who registered. Please feel
free forward it to any friends,
colleagues, Uncle Joe, whoever you think
will benefit from everything our council
of comedy shared with us today.
And remember, laughter is the best
medicine. Have a great rest of your day,
everybody. Bye-bye.
Bye now.